gigi hadid and zayn malik are going
their separate ways
word of the couple split comes mere
hours after details emerged about a
stunning accusation involving zayn and
gigi's mother yolanda hadid a source
tells e.t quote gigi and zayn broke up
after the incident with yolanda the two
have been co-parenting but they are not
together they tried to make things work
for their daughter but it wasn't working
out the now former couple welcomed
daughter kai last year
before the news of the breakup dropped
zayn was on the defense
with the singer speaking out after being
accused of hitting yolanda during an
argument
zane released a statement saying he
quote adamantly denies he struck yolanda
adding quote for the sake of my daughter
i declined to give any further details
and i hope that yolanda will reconsider
her false allegations
and move towards healing these family
issues in private
as for the alleged incident a source
tells e.t that the two had a
disagreement that quote turned hostile
quote yolanda is telling people around
her that zayn struck her yolanda is
extremely upset and it has caused issues
with zayn and gigi meanwhile a rep for
gigi tells et she quote is solely
focused on the best for kai she asks for
privacy during this time
et has reached out to yolanda and zane's
reps for further comments
zane shared his reaction after tmz broke
the story on thursday posting this
lengthy message to twitter
he wrote in part
quote as you all know i am a private
person and i very much want to create a
safe and private space for my daughter
to grow up in a place where private
family matters aren't thrown on the
world stage for all to poke and pick
apart
in an effort to protect that space for
her i agreed to not contest claims
arising from an argument i had with a
family member of my partners who entered
our home while my partner was away
several weeks ago zane ended the
statement by saying he hopes that there
will be quote healing for all involved
despite some apparently quote harsh
words he claimed were
[Music]
zayn and shared have been together for
years starting in 2015.
he's obviously so gorgeous but
really the way that we could have
conversations and kind of just
were really interested in the same
things and it was really easy so that
was amazing gg starred in the music
video for zayn's single pillow talk
the two took at least one extended break
from one another
but in early 2020 gigi confirmed that
she and the former one directioner were
back together
by announcing that they were expecting
their first child together on the
tonight show we're very excited and and
happy and grateful for everyone's well
wishes and support so
she also revealed that she and zane had
been quarantining with gigi's family and
like especially during this time it's
nice
it's a nice silver lining to be able to
like be home and together and like
really
experience it day by day after kai came
into the world
zane wrote on twitter quote the love i
feel for this tiny human is beyond my
understanding grateful to know her proud
to call her mine and thankful for the
life we will have together
and last month yolanda shared a sweet
birthday tribute for her granddaughter
she wrote in part quote no words can
express how much love and joy you have
brought into our lives
adding quote thank you to your
incredible mama gigi and bubba zane for
the greatest gift of life
and back in 2017 yolanda praised her
eldest daughter's partner while speaking
to e.t he's just a really good person
you know he comes from very humble
beginnings so he's just a normal guy and
he's a good human being